ils sont dix comme le jury goncourt ils
vont déjeuner ensemble comme les
goncourt
ils vont décerner leur prix comme leurs
aînés 1988 première édition du goncourt
des lycéens organisé notamment par la
fnac
un jury de lycéens qui a décidé de faire
comme les grands chaque année le prix
goncourt est décerné dans un restaurant
à paris celui d'elie siens dans un
restaurant à rennes 2 restaurants mais
une seule et même ambiance
constatez par vous même à gauche les
aînés ont pris leurs quartiers dans le
célèbre restaurant parisien le trou en
qui accueille les jurés depuis 1914 à
droite
les plus jeunes se retrouvent à la chope
la plus vieille brasserie rennaise et
les ressemblances sont frappantes
pour cette première édition l'auteur
erik orsenna se voir remettre le premier
prix goncourt des lycéens pour son
oeuvre
l'exposition coloniale pour le décerner
et les lycéens font comme les grands
absolument tout y est
conférence de presse menu gastronomique
journalistes une personne déléguée pour
annoncer le vainqueur bref c'est du
copier coller le prix goncourt des
jeunes rennais a été attribué à monsieur
erik orsenna pour son livre
l'exposition coloniale et l'écorcé n'a
récompensé chez les jeunes est ce que le
vainqueur sera différent chez les
anciens en tout cas c'était le souhait
de la présidente du jury des lycéens à
peu près dix minutes on va voir le
résultat du véritable prix goncourt qui
va être proclamés à paris selon vous
qu'est-ce qu'elle plus intéressant que
votre résultat soit le même où qu'ils
soient différents
je pense que ça peut être une expérience
pour les lycéens d'abord qui s'amène
afin qu'il choisisse un bon choix de
lecture mais bon si le sujet différent
je pense que c'est
c'est peut-être mieux quelques minutes
plus tard c'est au tour des plus grande
récompense un auteur
attention roulements de tambour
le vainqueur des courses j'ai mis ces on
peut être capable de choisir un type de
lecture et être du même avis que dès que
des adultes quoi erik orsenna à nouveau
titré deux prix à 20 15
depuis 1988 d'autres auteurs ont reçu le
goncourt et le goncourt des lycéens
jean vautrin en 1989 pierre combescot en
91 ou encore andreï makine en 1995
[Musique]